Let's make our GitHub account.
>> Okay. So I'm going to call it 2048-class. Okay, and
then I'll do the free play, and I"m sure that's fine. Right?
>> Yeah.
>> That doesn't seem to do anything, but
I don't want to enter my credit card number
>> Hm.
>> Maybe I can, okay set up my account.
>> Let's see. Yeah, let's just see if we can go
to the account. It looks like it's set up. I don't know.
I guess we don't need to put in a credit card.
>> Alright, so we have an account. What's, what do we do next?
>> Well so we, first we need to install Git.
And so there, there are two ways to access Git.
>> What is, what is Git?
>> It's the version control system itself.
>> Okay.
>> So GitHub is just a place to store Git repos, repositories. So
we actually need the, the software on our computer to, to actually make the
Git commits and run all the Git commands.
>> Okay. So, should I, does Git have software like that?
>> So there, there is a get hub specific UI that could
handles Git for you, and it installs Git when you install it. So.
>> Okay.
>> We can go ahead and use the Git gooey.
>> So I'm going to just search for
that. What I, what should I search for? GitHub?
>> Gui?
>> yeah,
that'll probably get us there.
>> Get us there.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Okay, I'll do GitHub for Mac.
>> Yeah, we want the one for Mac.
>> Okay, easy enough.
>> There it goes.
>> Alright, so we've downloaded it, unzipped it. Now, let's install.
Alright.
>> Alright, so we've installed it. We opened it,
and now we have this folder that says My Repositories.
>> Yep. So now we actually need to get our repository
>> Okay.
>> To put in there.